donc maintenant place aux hommes alors
il était une fois non
maintenant
n'avait aucune intention cette phrase
je reprends il était une fois un second
rôle masculin dans une série américaine
à des milliers de kilomètres une jeune
spectatrice frappé par le charisme de
l'acteur pensait devant son téléviseur
oh my god c'est qui ce mec c'est qui ce
génie le talent de l'acteur irradiait le
monde entier et ne tarderai pas ça ça ne
tarderait pas à se savoir depuis la
spectatrice était particulièrement
attentive aux seconds rôles cette série
s'applique girl's et la spectatrice
c'était moi
il était une fois la naissance d'un
grand acteur à qui elle ne pensais pas
un jour dire hello adam driver
bravo
pliable you have my eternal respecte
as oui saillir
les pavés pour le césar du meilleur
second rôle dans un rôle masculin sont